à moins de deux semaines du scrutin ils
veulent convaincre
opération tractage pour ces militants
communistes
j'en ai devant ce centre de tri
d'anciens postiers venus défendre un
service public au plus près des
habitants on arrête de fermer les
bureaux de poste
le bureau de poste c'est dans un village
c'est hyper important comme un facteur
et je pense que fabien roussel ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est mon poste comme on a
connu il ya quinze ou vingt ans en
arrière plus de services pour les
usagers de meilleurs salaires pour les
travailleurs le pc veut parler aux
classes populaires mais loin des autres
gauches juge est déconnecté et hautaine
la pâte roussel c'est d'abord la
promesse des jours heureux qu'on puisse
effectivement un peu respirer en il
envoie là on a une perspective politique
qui pourrait nous sortir un petit peu de
la situation connaît avec le droit à
vivre normalement le droit à la culture
le droit le droit au social le droit à
un frère braveraient emploi un vrai
salaire et alors que la campagne entre
dans sa dernière ligne droite fabien
roussel a rejeté ce matin sur france
info l'idée d'un vote utile est logique
moi je fais pas l'élection
présidentielle le nez sur les sondages
je fais l'élection présidentielle en
regardant les français en regardant mon
pays et en leur disant que le 10 avril
non seulement ils peuvent voter pour
leurs convictions pour leurs idées pour
le meilleur dont ils jugent être le plus
proche parce qu'il se retrouve dans ses
propos selon un dernier sondage fabien
roussel est créditée de 3,5 pour cent
des voix pour la première fois depuis 50
ans le parti communiste pourrait
devancer le parti socialiste